de días
el creador
omnipotente
y más misericordiosos que las
bendiciones del todopoderoso brillan en
el profeta mahoma y sus
sucesores y descendencia
el sagrado corán
declara
[Música]
qué gran creador omnipotente del mundo
no acepta nuestro respecto
para con sus mensajeros
26 el profeta mahoma que trajeron el
mensaje de espiritualidad de buena
conducta compasión que trajeron a los
pueblos del mundo
y destruyeron
los enlaces
de la injusticia
para permitir que los seres humanos
construyeron un nuevo mundo
en su futuro señoras y señores señor
secretario general
se necesita un nuevo mundo con las bases
sobre la justicia
teniendo en cuenta las expectativas de
la humanidad lo cual se basa en la
justicia
y tienen la capacidad de crearle este
marco cavar que la justicia lo cual
supone eliminar la injusticia
somos los defensores en una lucha en
contra de la injusticia en todas sus
manifestaciones
injusticias contra la humanidad la
espiritualidad del todopoderoso a los
pueblos del mundo independientemente de
donde se dé
y quisiera aproximar al creador y sus
enseñanzas
que existen en toda la humanidad y la
disposición de cambio se ha visto en las
revoluciones a lo largo de la historia
de manera aun cuando muchos movimientos
no llegan a la madurez de una revolución
muchas de ellas se han desviado de su
vía original pero el éxito de muchos
pueblos y naciones como la nación del
irán en cuanto al logro de sus
aspiraciones en mi mente una revolución
islámica fortaleció en el fort interno
de los pelos del mundo esas aspiraciones
en la revolución islámica del irán
fue logro de un movimiento del popular
del irán a favor de la justicia equidad
aun cuando se afrontaba
una serie de confabulaciones a lo largo
de diseños pero apoyo salvaguardarse
como primer medida la nación del irán
sobre la base de un orden social
avanzado
y estableció la república islámica del
irán
con el propósito de que hubiese justicia
interna y llevar
orden mundial el mensaje de la justicia
equidad
los elementos clave
en este camino
de espiritualidad
multilateralismo
y señoras y señores
agradezco completamente y es un honor
ser el representante de un pueblo y de
una nación que recibió el legado de una
gran civilización
que ha gozado libertad durante milenios
y que siempre ha logrado
derrotar las confabulaciones del enemigo
que pretendía conquistarla una nación
que siempre ha conocido la opresión como
enemigo existencial y siempre ha
obrador
a poner coto a la esclavitud es de los
babilonios hasta los palestinos creemos
en un destino común para la humanidad y
estamos a favor de la mundialización de
la justicia lo que buscamos para
nosotros se los deseamos también al
prójimo lo que no deseamos para nosotros
no lo hemos imponer al prójimo la nación
del irán sabe que la justicia lleva
unidad a que la cohesión y la guerra
destruye y lo destruye todo
para un país que internamente
desea que haya justicia
pero fuera de sus fronteras cree o
capacita grupos terroristas y los
desencadena para que vayan a otras
naciones tendría que sentir vergüenza
ante la humanidad y ante los principios
de libertad justicia la humanidad no
sólo le pertenece a algunos sectores del
mundo
la república islámica del irán
al tener en cuenta
y los principios constitucionales y los
principios espirituales en los que se
avanza
de que la una de las maneras más
eficaces de salvaguardar los derechos
humanos
se ha valido de la sed
herramientas más útiles
con miras a
lograr y ayudar a lograr los derechos de
todos los oprimidos en el orbe y lo ve
como uno de sus deberes inherentes la
república islámica del irán rechazan los
dobles raseros de algunos gobiernos con
respecto a derechos humanos y lo ven
como el factor más importante
qué ha hecho trivial el tema de los
derechos humanos ante los ojos de muchos
diría que se trata
de algo
que se está dando en este momento que se
está dando en la república islámica del
irán donde ya hemos entablado todos ya
luego respecto a la muerte de decenas de
mujeres inocentes en países occidentales
si se sigue con los toques traseros de
atención solo se dirigirá a un lado y no
habrá equidad no habrá justicia los
derechos humanos pertenecen a todos pero
lamentablemente los han pisoteado muchos
los han pisoteado muchos gobiernos
los pueblos oriundos de canadá
cuyos
restos mortales de muchos de sus hijos
se encontraron en fosas comunes en sus
escuelas los derechos de los palestinos
que se ven pisoteados por la ocupación
aquellos que han sido víctimas del
terrorismo aquellos que buscan y anhelan
la libertad del refugio pero ven que a
sus hijos se les encierra en jaulas todo
esto es prueba de que
el lugar del acusador y el tc
y no se debe juzgar únicamente como los
representanes y caracterizan unos sino
que precisan de una base que hace falta
en en muchos lugares para reivindicar el
derecho de salvaguardar los derechos
humanos
cuando hacemos mención de
los actos salvajes del estado islámico
que esclavizaron
minorías religiosas yazidis hombres y
mujeres que muestra que cuando llegamos
a participar para derrotarlos
comprobamos que estábamos defendiendo
los derechos humanos y los que apoyaron
al estado islámico con el levante-
tuvieron que estar sentados en el
banquillo de los acusados
señoras y señores hoy por hoy asistimos
a un cambio del orden mundial 1 un mundo
unilateral de hegemonía un mundo en el
que
el poder financiero
controlar la conducta en donde las
acciones el delictiva a percibirse en
las naciones y el uso de organizaciones
internacionales como herramienta de
opresión o que ejercer presión sobre
naciones indefensas colones o sea que
estamos hablando de un mundo en el que
no hay ni justicia ni equidad
y por esa pérdida apoyo en cuanto a las
personas y los pueblos de todo el mundo
indudable que se creara un nuevo orden
del líbano a los territorios palestinos
ocupados
en toda nuestra región vemos
que hay
un sistema antiguo con políticas que son
un fracaso ahora vemos
terrorismo
veo que no se respeta ni las religiones
ni las culturas autóctonas
y qué sé
se está en contra del multilateralismo
algo injusto y todo eso ha creado
grandes retos grandes problemas para el
progreso humano
estamos convencidos
de que para enfrentar los retos
cualquier reto además de cualquier marco
en el mundo nuestra única opción es que
haya coherencia que haya unidad a partir
del multilateralismo y de la justicia a
partir de los valores humanos
compartidos
de los enseñan de las enseñanzas divinas
no hay otro camino
creemos que todos los naciones que
buscan la paz
consideran muy caros esos valores tan
arraigados y que la defensa de todos
estos valores contra los opresores del
mundo depende de nosotros lo que
queremos es que es el derecho de la
nación iraní y del pueblo iraní
sus derechos es una relación basada en
opresión no se tolerará
así que
defenderemos orgullosamente los derechos
de nuestro pueblo de nuestra nación
creemos que cualquier acción opresor es
una acción contra la paz y la
estabilidad del mundo
y eso es una amenaza para todo el mundo
conseguir la seguridad en todo el mundo
por cualquier vía que no sea la justicia
no será ni sos ni sostenible ni
permanente y precisamente esperamos que
lo sea a través de las naciones unidas
que apoye que haga que sea posible
evidentemente la justicia es algo
difícil de ejecutar y quizá por eso
muchos de los que dicen que están de
parte de la paz
no asumen la responsabilidad de la paz
así que a ellos les decimos
puesto que ustedes no quieren cargar con
ese fardo
no quieren luchar realmente contra la
opresión
nosotros estamos convencidos de la
cultura coránica que dice que no debemos
o que no se debe ser opresor de oprimir
a nadie y la suerte de muchas naciones
están vinculadas a esos principios
que
no acatan la lógica del carácter de la
justicia y de la equidad van en contra
del multilateralismo a favor de las de
los opresores una nación sin lógica
se basa en los golpes de estados el
intervencionismo militar
el poderío militar
y tienen una mantiene una lucha
selectiva contra el terrorismo y el uso
de las armas nucleares
va a llevar realmente al mundo a que
esté más cerca de la justicia la equidad
y la paz o será la base del poder
hegemónico
el que se mate a tantísimos niños
iraquíes y yemeníes etcétera para qué
sirve
no sera
que demuestra que hay una falta total de
justicia y de equidad en el mundo
y qué es lo que quiere la república
islámica del irán
lo que quiere es que se cumpla su
derecho lógico justo
y eso ha causado estragos entre los
opresores del mundo queridos colegas hoy
la disposición
de apoyar la hegemonía
se ha convertido en un un gran problema
para la humanidad que es una gran
amenaza el deseo de las naciones del
mundo
es cada vez más obtener la justicia la
independiencia
disfrutando de seguridad también
él
el que haya un frente de resistencia de
muestra
repito
el que haya una doctrina de resistencia
demuestra que hay una gran voluntad por
parte de muchos de que hay una verdadera
justicia mientras que el unilateralismo
ha sido un instrumento
piano que se ha utilizado para mantener
atrás a muchos países de forma selectiva
los eeuu no pueden aceptar que algunos
países tengan derecho a ser mantenerse
por sí solos
y confunden el militarismo con la
seguridad y los amigos de los estados
unidos viven algo semejante lo que se
observa
en europa ahora ocurrido en asia
occidentales los últimos 20 años el
comportamiento y el resultado del
movimiento de contingentes militares en
esas regiones ha dado los mismos
resultados porque en todos los casos
aquí nada ha demostrado que la suerte de
muchos países
ha demostrado que los eeuu defendían sus
intereses a costa de los intereses de
tantos otros países señor secretario
general queridos colegas la revolución
islámica en irán fue el inicio de un
movimiento de la gran nación de irán
de buscar ocupar su propio lugar en el
mundo y a lo largo de los decenios ha
habido hemos visto golpes de estado
sanciones opresivas
e intervenciones y hegemónicas pero
ninguno de los éxitos de la nación iraní
han sido aceptables para los grandes
potencias desde que el primer presidente
difuntos señor rachel
y demostró que había habido grandes
torturas y llegó a este estrado hace más
de 40 años y demostró que tenía
todavía
cicatrices de la tortura a manos de la
policía secreta del tsja
y después fue castigado por los
hipócritas
un decenio después
el ayatolá jomeiní
pudo impedir que hubiera una agresión
en el territorio iraní y que esto
estuviera a cargo de su propio destino
el pueblo iraní ha estado ha sido
víctima del terrorismo y se ha
convertido hoy en día
un pueblo con el que se puede contar
para luchar contra el terrorismo en toda
la región hoy en día la república
islámica del irán
para conseguir hacer realidad sus
aspiraciones de justicia
ha dedicado gran capital a ello desde
que sadam husein
rome a cabo con el acuerdo de argel y
atacó a irán de forma no provocada hasta
que el gobierno de los eeuu
pisoteó el acuerdo nuclear
y vimos otras caras del comportamiento
criminal contra la humanidad
hace algún tiempo el presidente anterior
de los eeuu de américa anunció
que ir había sido creado por los estados
unidos de américa para nosotros da
igualdad
hilda es
fue creada por un gobierno de los eeuu
otra administración lo que importa es
que un gobierno de la otra parte del
planeta decidió llevar el caos causar
estragos en la geografía de nuestra
región
a costa de la vida y de la sangre de las
mujeres y los niños y de los inocentes
pero al ver
la resistencia de la república islámica
pudo acabar con ese movimiento
destructor y el líder
de la lucha contra el terrorismo fue el
querido difunto mártir general sole
maniobra
un hombre
que buscaba
la libertad y que fue mártir mientras
trabajaba para conseguir la libertad de
las naciones de la región
y el presidente anterior de los eeuu de
américa
firmó el
documentos de ese crimen salvaje ilegal
inmoral
y lo que se dijo
tal cual demuestra
que la opresión que se impone contra las
naciones de la región
de tal forma
ha conseguido que se restañan las
heridas de algunos de los corazones
rotos
a que dio lugar este crimen es que se
persiga la justicia ante un crimen que
el presidente de los eeuu admitió
haber firmado
es algo que no se olvidará
a través de un tribunal justo
haremos que haya jus que lleguen a la
justicia los que convirtieron en mártir
a nuestro querido general solemne
señoras y señores la historia del iraní
es la historia de una nación que ha
aprendido a mantenerse en pie sin
depender de nadie
irán aprendió esta lección
después de que las dos guerras mundiales
anunció su neutralidad y sin embargo en
ambas guerras
fue objeto de ocupación extranjera
y en los años 50 posteriormente cuando
se acercó a los eeuu y confió en ella
para conseguir la nacionalización de la
industria del petróleo un sueño nacional
también se la defraudó
y después de la firma del acuerdo
nuclear después de que fuera aceptado en
el marco
del consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas
ni siquiera sé respecto se pisoteó
unilateralmente señor secretario general
señoras y señores la nación de dirán ha
aprendido cuáles son las en qué consiste
la política de la resistencia y del
progreso
en la que nos hemos concentrado
por qué
un orden social avanzado
en el que vive la república islámica
hoy pese a las sanciones ha conseguido
grandes logros en la esfera de la
tecnología de los conocimientos
conocimientos especializados y creemos
que el mundo y necesita a un irán fuerte
tenemos la capacidad de exportar
además de el petróleo y el gas tenemos
redes de distribución de electricidad
a través de nuestra gran nación
y en cuanto a los conocimientos la
biociencia la nanotecnología las
ciencias nucleares vamos a la vanguardia
y el crecimiento del irán en estos
sectores es considerable
y demuestra nuestros esfuerzos sociales
en muchos casos por ejemplo intentamos
que hubiera una cobertura social
universal para 85 millones de personas y
en iu hemos perseguido que se hiciera
realidad la voluntad de la población esa
es la base del sistema de la república
islámica del irán
y durante la guerra impuesta
por parte del irak contra el irán ni
siquiera pudimos
comprar alambre espino sin embargo ya
podemos fabricarlo
gracias a los conocimientos y las
capacidades autóctonas
los sistemas más modernos necesarios
para defender a nuestra nación
pueblos del mundo queridos colegas señor
secretario general
no es que nuestros enemigos dieron un
paso atrás sino que nuestra nación
consiguió
quitar a sus enemigos participando de
forma sin precedentes en la re evolución
islámica
para arraigar los valores de la fe
y de la voluntad divina
y luego la política de relaciones de
buena voz vecindad de progreso en las
relaciones económicas y comerciales se
han convertido en un elemento
fundamental de la política exterior de
nuestra república y queremos
que haya unas relaciones amplias con
todas las naciones del mundo sobre todo
con nuestros vecinos
la guerra no es la solución a las crisis
el diálogo
las condensaciones las negociaciones son
las verdaderas soluciones en la
república islámica del irán
como país poderoso en la región
está presente está dispuesto a resolver
las crisis lo he hecho en los últimos
años
y el comercio regional de tirán
ha aumentado de forma
sorprendente
y ahora estamos en una nueva época de
expansión con los países vecinos de las
relaciones de buena vecindad que llevan
estabilidad
para todos hemos demostrado que en los
momentos más difíciles
que todos los países de nuestro de
nuestro contexto somos verdaderos amigos
las verdaderas conversaciones que hemos
tenido con líderes regionales
en todas ellas una de las cosas que se
ha mencionado es que la seguridad
regional
debe venir de dentro y no del exterior
y que la forma de conseguirlo es que
haya colaboración y cooperación
no formando bloques que se opongan entre
sí sino que tiene que haber relaciones
de buena vecindad hermanas
si dejamos la suerte de la región en sus
manos los ocupantes se irán y serán los
vecinos los que queden ayudándose los
unos a los otros hasta la eternidad
en un pasado no tan distante vimos las
hogueras de la guerra entre los dos
países hermanos de irak e irán
algo que alentaron las potencias
enemigas del mundo pero hoy vemos las
marchas de alba in
para cumplir
40 días del martirio ya la ucm vemos
que se observa
esa conmemoración
reforzamos nuestros valores y respetamos
a los que dieron la vida a los
descendientes del proceso que dieron la
vida por la dignidad humana y los
valores humanos
queridos colegas quisiera señalar su
atención
una de las cuestiones más atroces que
demuestran que las potencias
están presentes en la región la región
no había visto antes
potencia es tan ocupado tan atroces como
el asesinato de
de mujeres y niños por parte del régimen
sionista' que ha creado la mayor cárcel
del mundo en caza y la construcción la
expansión de los asentamientos de
viviendas ilegales en territorio
palestino en granjas palestinas el
asesinato de sus niños de las nuevas
generaciones demuestra a todo el mundo
que 70 años de ocupación israelí y de
salvajismo por su parte
es algo que nos sigue
afectando que no acaba pero las
potencias mundiales deben demostrar
porque siguen evitando las soluciones
que propone la república islámica del
irán
para resolver la crisis palestina
todos los territorios palestinos
todo el territorio palestina de las
regiones montañosas hasta el mar no
necesitan más que una solución que es
qué
y la voz de los palestinos musulmanes
judíos palestinos se dejen sentir en un
referéndum que sea completo
la potencia ocupante sionista que ocupó
jerusalén y otros territorios de la
región no puede ser un aliado de la
seguridad y la estabilidad
queridos colegas
quisiera señalar su atención otra fase
de la falta de justicia
qué es el doble rasero que se aplica
cuando se habla de capacidades nucleares
capacidades nucleares científicas de la
república islámica del irán sabemos que
sólo con fines civiles pacíficos pero
algunos países están dispuestos a
utilizarlo como amenaza
que no para no tener que enfrentar lo
que tienen que enfrentar ellos mismos
que es la desnuclearización y yo anuncie
como líder del gobierno de la república
islámica del irán
que nuestro país no quiere construir ni
obtener armas nucleares y que esas armas
no tienen lugar alguno en nuestra
doctrina
y esto es en el marco de una fatua
oficial anunciada por su eminente el
líder supremo a miami nin y una sería
una fatua basada en la sharía
de su eminencia es mucho más valiosa que
cualquier medida con organismos externos
o internacionales y todo esto tiene
lugar en un contexto en el que los
propios países
quieren señalar los injustamente como
amenaza y sin embargo siguen
desarrollando y ensayando armas
nucleares y han regalado esas armas al
gobierno sionista
y esos gobiernos que deben ser
desarmados
son premiados pero los que cumplen con
los marcos adecuados son incluso
amenazados con medidas del tnp
y en un marco en el que únicamente el 2%
de las actividades nucleares del mundo
tiene lugar en irán irán sin embargo ha
sido objeto del 85% de las inspecciones
nucleares y voy a repetir únicamente el
2 por ciento de las actividades
nucleares del mundo tiene lugar en el
iraní el 85 por ciento de las
inspecciones nucleares se llevan a cabo
en el irán así que
les pregunto a todos los que están aquí
presentes hoy les pido por favor que se
centra en los siguientes puntos con
precisión 1 la república islámica del
irán tiene buena voluntad y por eso
firmó un acuerdo lo aceptó en 2015 y en
una primera fase
cumplió con todos sus compromisos sin
excepción alguna pero el resultado de
eso fue que los eeuu
pisotearon el acuerdo
y dijeron tal cual
que eran medidas de sanción sin
precedentes
la sanción son un castigo que se impone
al pueblo iraní
por buscar la paz la libertad se
disculpa al intérprete un arma de
destrucción en masa eso es lo que son
las sanciones
cumplir con ello o cooperar en suez para
su ejecución es algo que ayuda a
arraigar la opresión y dos fueron los
estados unidos.los que pisotearon el
acuerdo no fue federal el organismo
internacional de energía atómica emitió
15 informes que decían exactamente que
el irán
había seguido plenamente comprometido
con todos sus compromisos número 3
pagó el precio de haber cumplido con sus
compromisos y sin embargo
consecuencia de que los eeuu nos
respetarán y que los europeos estuvieran
cooperando con los eeuu
en la república islámica del irán ha
conseguido los beneficios del acuerdo
ha habido muchas oportunidades para los
que pisotearon el acuerdo para que
pudieran volver a er hemos sido
sumamente flexibles y si no hubiera sido
por ello
las negociaciones se habrían acabado en
los primeros días la lógica de las
negociaciones
para nosotros es un análisis justo de lo
que está ocurriendo y nuestro deseo no
es más que uno el compromiso la
observancia el cumplimiento de los
compromisos y ahora
la cuestión de las garantías no es sólo
para algo que pueda ocurrir sino que nos
estamos basando en la experiencia real
hablamos de la experiencia de que los
eeuu
abandonaron el jc pero a
y ha habido un año y medio de
negociaciones con la administración
americana actual para que vuelva a
cumplir con sus compromisos y hoy están
hablando de que están cumpliendo sus
compromisos con respecto a este acuerdo
pero sin embargo siguen repitiendo las
mismas historias del pasado lo que hace
que se dude mucho de su verdadero
compromiso en cuanto a volver al acuerdo
y eso nos lleva a otra cuestión
realmente podemos confiar sin garantías
en que van a cumplir esta vez con sus
compromisos evidentemente la república
islámica del irán
mediante esas relaciones duraderas bien
arraigadas con los países ha podido
neutralizar muchas veces las sanciones y
generar nuevas oportunidades según los
eeuu de américa
tal como anunciaron muchos funcionarios
de ese gobierno la máxima
medida de presión ha sido un fracaso
vergonzoso
hemos sido
hemos mantenido mantenía nuestra
independencia en el pasado vamos a
seguir haciéndolo y al mismo tiempo
somos muy serios en las negociaciones y
hemos demostrado hemos probado que si se
respetan los derechos del pueblo iraní
entonces habrá una verdadera voluntad de
resolver todos los problemas creemos
que el acuerdo nuclear debe estar
abierto y el nudo desde el mismo punto
en el que conseguimos anudar los juntos
distinguidos representantes de las
naciones
la última parte de mi intervención ante
ustedes
es la mención de esta necesidad que se
tiene todo el mundo de que haya justicia
equidad todos nosotros todos los seres
humanos tenemos que ser parte de la
construcción activa de un mundo nuevo
basado en la justicia en los valores
humanos si queremos que haya un mundo
nuevo
aceptable
que tenga carácter que sea poderoso que
tenga éxito en la resolución de los
problemas que enfrenta la humanidad
no hay más solución que el que se base
en la justicia
en la equidad internacional a partir de
los siguientes principios uno
que nos sintamos responsables como
colectivo
de luchar contra la opresión número 2 el
respeto de la voluntad de los pueblos y
naciones y el que nos abstengamos
de la interacción directa de la
injerencia interna en sus asuntos
internos 3 la eliminación de los dobles
raseros número 4
plantar cara a la violencia y la guerra
5 independencia y prudencia en las
acciones de las organizaciones
internacionales y lo más importante es
la creación
que haya personas dignas con experiencia
que puedan crear este nuevo sistema
así es como concebimos el futuro y
creemos que es muy realista y estamos
convencidos de que a partir de las
promesas divinas que nos transmitieron
los profetas la justicia
reinará en el mundo
y los que son verdaderos seguidores de
los mandamientos divinos serán
bendecidos con la reaparición
del último mes ya muchas gracias
sinceramente por su amable atención
y dios les bendiga dios omnipotente